Well,
let me start with why I got interested
in writing about it.
Uh,
I was directing a bioethics center in
Australia and we were contacted by
doctors who had ethical dilemmas.
They were working in a neonatal
intensive care units,
intensive care units for very small
children.
And they had,
uh,
conditions,
which for example,
a spinal Bifida in which in their view
it was not really a good thing for these
babies to survive.
Um,
the babies if they did survive would
need multiple operations,
uh,
would be severely disabled,
in various wise and uh,
often the parents also thought that
given the description of the condition,
it was not going to be a good thing for
the babies to survive.
So these babies were essentially being
not treated and the result of being not
treated was that by mostly died before
they were six months old.
Almost all of them died before they're
six months old.
Some of them died in the first week or
two,
some of the first month or two and
others.
Gradually throughout that first six
months.
And this was a very draining experience
for the parents,
the doctors,
the nurses.
You had these small babies in the
hospital,
but not being treated in order to,
uh,
to make them live.
Um,
but nevertheless living for quite a long
time.
And the doctor said,
you know,
how are we doing the right thing here?
Is this justifiable?
So we,
my colleague,
Helga cruiser,
and I looked at it and we decided that
yes,
it was a reasonable decision for the
parents and doctors to make that it was
better than infants with this condition
should not live based with the most
severe variants of this condition should
not live,
but we couldn't defend the idea that the
right thing to do then was to let them
die.
Um,
this same slow and painful and as I
said,
uh,
terribly emotionally draining on the
parents and others.
So we said,
look,
the difficult decision is whether you
want this infant to live or not.
Um,
that should be a decision for the
parents and doctors to make on the basis
of the fullest possible information
about what the condition is.
But once you've made that decision,
it should be permissible to make sure
that baby dies swiftly and humanely.
If,
if that's the decision.
If your decision is that it's better
that the child should not live,
it should be possible to ensure that the
child dies swiftly and you mainly.
Uh,
and so that's what we,
that's what we proposed.
Now
that's been picked up by a variety of
opponents,
both pro life movement people and,
uh,
people in the militant disability
movement,
which,
which incidentally didn't really exist
at the time.
We wrote,
uh,
we first write about this issue,
and they've taken us as,
you know,
the stalking horse,
the bogey man if you like.
Um,
uh,
because we're up at front in saying that
we think this is how we should treat
these infants.
Uh,
I can understand to some extent why the
pro life movement takes us that way,
but I think the disability movement or
to be just as upset about letting
children die because they have a
disability.
And since that's a very common practice
in many hospitals,
I'm not so sure why they've gone after
us in particular,
rather than after the doctors who are
actually doing it.
Uh,
because I really don't see the
difference between letting the children
die and making sure that their death
comes swiftly and humanely.